yeah I mean like our first like full
year I think you already shared it well
you said 20 is 40. but uh yeah we did
about 40 million dollars and then
um you know this year we're on track to
do 30 35 growth yeah
um it's it's crazy
so we are here in the uh
yeah the shed yeah like this studio like
I'm looking at the video it looks legit
yeah people don't know what's looks like
from the outside this is definitely like
a sketchy um like I've seen a Netflix
documentary about a shed like this well
you got here five minutes later than we
did it was it was like 100 degrees in
here
I was like this is gonna be a sweaty
podcast and this is uh you guys are
different than I'll say our normal
guests which are almost always like I
don't know a business like tech software
type of entrepreneur uh y'all are
entrepreneurs in a different way and
you're Instagram famous so that's cool
that's amazing
um you tagged me in a story yesterday
and I gotta say my wife has never looked
at me that way before she was like oh so
she's never listened to one episode of
this podcast we've done many 400
episodes she's not a podcast person in
general like she's listening to anyone's
podcast yeah
but you would think maybe she'll listen
yeah there's just not a lot of like time
to like do things like that yeah I get
it but I think she'll listen to this one
so I'm excited because uh she's a fan of
yours and uh and so we hung out at
dinner last night got to know each other
a little bit so I'm excited maybe we'll
do like you guys give like a 60 second
intro yeah who you guys are what why
introduce yourselves to the audience
sure
um I'll go first so my name is Danny
Austin and I started uh creating content
online about 10 years ago I was actually
living in Austin I was at the University
of Texas sophomore like just making
videos on YouTube in my in my dorm room
um you know kind of just grew from there
really fast thank God on Instagram all
the other platforms we now run Divi
which is a scalp care uh hair care
product brand
um and we do that together we have a lot
of fun doing that honestly online we
just share anything about our lives from
like be having two kids under two to
um you know fast or affordable fashion
um yeah we've kind of been doing that
together for you know five years so
she's been online for 10 years you know
we met we didn't work together until we
got married I was in like Austin Tech
scene before we got married and then uh
you know I was telling you last night
this just became a lifestyle and it was
all consuming and so she would be in
like Turks and Caicos and I would be in
a boardroom and I'd be like oh my gosh
like what am I doing in my life and so
around 2018 we took the leap to work
together jumped into kind of like the
influencer space which we it didn't have
a name before that it was just like we
created content and then I think the
media started covering it a lot more
and then they labeled me an Instagram
husband and then they uh labeled our
industry you know how do you feel like
our label you know it's fine like I'm
glad that I did it wait that's so not
true at first yeah it's true
like what are you doing he's like
um you never knew well when you're
coming out of college like you know so
much of your identity is wrapped up in
your title especially being here in
Austin Texas like you know in the tech
scene it was like oh what startup are
you part of do you have funding you know
what's your title what employee number
were you and so I was still kind of
caught up in that mindset and then you
know we jumped in together it was like I
remember the first article that came out
was by a writer named Taylor Lorenz and
she wrote an article about what is the
Instagram history with Taylor the Reds
too yeah really yeah yeah dude it's
crazy a lot of people have a history
with her now but uh you know she so she
she wrote that article and she quoted me
in it and then I was like labeled the
Instagram husband but uh yeah and so we
we did the influencer industry for five
years together and just honestly created
content together and then covet hit and
Brands started really investing in that
space we should also say how this came
about yeah you listen to the Pod yes and
he's a huge fan I'm a huge fan and so we
I didn't know that I didn't know who you
were at that time but uh I did an
episode where I was talking about
Creator businesses yes so content
creators who have now spun off
businesses that are doing really well
that are not called Mr Beast it's like
okay everybody knows Mr B's yeah so who
are the who a lot of the other cool cool
examples and we did like maybe five six
seven examples and then Danny with with
Divi was one of them and so I guess you
heard that yeah well so like a couple
nights before I think I saw a tweet that
you were doing and you were like we're
doing episode on creator-led businesses
and I think I like told you told me
that'd be so cool oh you guys on Twitter
and you know like I was like oh man like
that would be cool if they recognized
Divi but we're in a a niche right that
is totally not your Niche like you know
you had no idea who Danny was I last
night Danny was like watching the first
couple episodes
I was like no this is Sean he's cool
um and uh yeah I I was on a plane a
couple days later listening to that
episode and then it was like oh have you
ever heard of Danny Austin you asked
that to Sam and Sam was like no that was
funny and then it was like uh yeah you
talked about Divi and I really
appreciate that so I sent a DM and I was
like hey man would love to come and
share a story it's very different than
most of the businesses y'all cover but
and let's play a little game uh we went
to dinner last night Chinese restaurant
we ordered food let's see how well you
know your husband I don't know if he
told you they're sorry alligator yeah oh
he brought out it's hard to check in the
busy order thing wait so you ordered
alligator
I did order it and and it was just kind
of like a spur of the moment thing there
was a couple things that were funny
about it I think he was trying to
impress us no I I was not trying to
impress you this is funny though like so
Matthew booked the dinner and it was uh
so Sam Ellinger used to play football at
UT Austin that's one of Matthew's really
good friends Matthew works for for Danny
and I and I go hey find a cool
restaurant in in Austin that you know we
can talk these people he books this like
upstairs room there's like a chandelier
it's a table for 16. and then and they
walk in I go Matthew this is such a
power move and then on top of that you
know the I'm like you know we're all
talking so I don't know what to order
and then he's like you should try the
alligator I was like okay I'll take the
alligator and they were like and then he
brought it home and woke me up and he
was like you gotta try this alligator
I'm sorry it really tastes like chicken
you should just try it okay so you
didn't try it out here yeah that was a
crazy proof uh I gotta give me credit I
will never enjoy it I'll never forget it
so yeah I guess that's maybe a lesson to
be learned yeah they go to a dinner with
somebody first time order the weirdest
thing on the menu
get it that's awesome so you guys uh you
started doing this back in 2012. uh
right around 2012 you're in college at
the time
what was because you know Instagram had
been out
um YouTube had been out for maybe five
years by that point but it sounds like
when you're talking about it it was very
early days back then what was what was
working back then how did like what
would you have a tiny following back
then like how did it what was this early
years like so the back story is my
brother Landon Austin he's actually a
musician and he started on YouTube he
just started posting covers of different
songs
um he had one video blow up because
people thought that he was John Mayer
it was actually covering taizon Days
Like Chocolate Rain Song anyway so that
popped off so my brother started to like
kind of acquire this audience and he
told me about the space but I thought it
was so weird like I'd walk by his
bedroom and he'd be like talking to all
of his imaginary friends and I just I
was like come on Landon like you got to
make some real friends and so um but he
ended up putting me in like a sibling
tag because tags were really popular on
YouTube back then you know like the
Chubby Bunny Challenge or whatever tag
so he put me in a video and you know in
all the comments it's like your sister
should start a Channel or she should
share how she did her makeup or where'd
she get her top and so my brother
actually made my channel for me and I
didn't touch it we went home over winter
break and we were so bored because you
know all of our friends are in Austin
now everyone's in college and um you
know I was just like you know what let's
give this thing a shot so my brother
filmed and edited my first video it was
all like just affordable New Year's Eve
outfits and it popped off and within
like three months I had a hundred
thousand followers and I just started
kind of posting consistently I knew of
like a handful of girls out in Los
Angeles that were doing this like full
time and they actually had managers and
there were agencies that were just
dedicated like specifically to YouTube
which was like a totally different world
So within three months I signed with a
manager
um and then every summer from then on
out I would just fly out to LA and do
collabs because collabs were like yeah
oh yeah collabs were everything they
actually had just opened YouTube space
and Playa Vista in Los Angeles as well
and they had this thing called The
Creator program where they only a lot of
think like 10 or 11 of us in and
creators of all sizes and we were for
you had to collab with two other
creators in the program in order to be
able to use YouTube space so like when
you got to YouTube space I mean they had
everything from like their you know a
red camera they had Studios they had you
know editing Bays editing Suites they
had all these classes you could take so
I would go and work for my manager from
like you know nine to five and then from
five to like nine I would go to YouTube
space and just collab make YouTube
videos learn about how to edit and
everything and you're like 21 at the
time yeah I'm 21. I was 20 actually it
was 19 20. I couldn't drink what are you
doing when you're working for your
manager well just by day you're like so
that's high yeah no I mean I was like
um in on like all of the negotiations
like a lot of the creators were moving
out to LA and the brands would come to
the office and you know meet all the
creators and I honestly learned
everything about like the back end of
the
yes and then like also being around all
these creators I would meet some of like
the girls that I loved and then get
their number and then we would collab
and everyone was very it was just very
collaborative everybody's helping each
other out
um so it was awesome and but then I was
able to kind of take all of that back to
Austin and there really weren't a lot of
you know YouTubers in Austin which also
kind of helped me because I felt like I
was one of the only ones and so
um when I was I did start kind of like
pitching myself to Brands because like I
also signed with my manager but she was
you know managing girls that had over a
million followers I had maybe 150 000 at
the time
um and so I started pitching myself to
all these like startups in Austin and
what I found was what was happening was
I was getting these brand deals or these
Partnerships I would you know get to
know them pull them in and then forward
them to my manager and then I would look
on YouTube and like all the other girls
that were signed with her would be
working with these Brands and I wasn't
so I was basically just like funneling
these Brands to my manager so I realized
at that time was like I'm not big enough
for them to care right so I need to get
out of this contract and just kind of
manage manage myself and build my own
team and like have people that actually
care about what I'm doing
um so as soon as I could I got out of
that contract and ever since then we've
always kind of had like an in-house team
um which we've learned a lot oh my gosh
from that but um yeah it's just kind of
crazy how it's evolved and so how even
when you were so how big is the audience
snap so now on Instagram like total
total on all of our platforms we have
probably over 2 million yeah 2.5 million
one is Instagram now main one is
Instagram which is like the perfect
platform for us um most of our content
is on Instagram stories and the reason
we like that is because it's kind of
like reality TV where I wake up with my
audience like like literally when I wake
up in the morning I get on stories and I
carry them throughout the entire day and
so it's just like the closest I feel
like people really feel like they're in
our homes you know it's it's very
stripped down yeah yeah it's a lot more
authentic it's kind of like follow all
of my day and so you uh you've done that
now you also launched Divi yes because
that's kind of how we when we initially
found you guys I read this thread I read
the Twitter thread somebody else
somebody else I've written about this
and
they named five or six creators I'd
never heard of that had businesses that
were really big it was like Divi uh
it's a you know this sort of like hair
care product whatever and it was doing
40 million or something in Revenue I
don't remember what the exact numbers
were but I remember being like wow
that's like really significant and so
cool like I never really
like I never heard of that you hear the
same three or four examples all the time
when it comes to like like Logan Paul
and Prime and Mr Beast and whatever like
especially in the tech world we kind of
hear the same we're not like as deep in
so you only hear this hear the same you
know three or four examples every single
time so how did that come about how did
you yeah when did you decide to instead
of posting for other people like let's
create our own brand and how did you
pick the product how did you like how
did you have the confidence to go for it
yeah so um there was definitely an era
on Instagram where everything was
perfect you know it's like back in the
day of like posting the perfect selfie
or the perfect like latte art whatever
it was
um and so I definitely played that game
and it gets very exhausting after a
while I started actually losing my hair
when I was in college whenever I was at
UT first it started with like just me
being so stressed out because I'm at UT
I'm flying to La every weekend I'm
posting on these videos I have like
neutrogena's like where is the brand
deal and I have like four exams the next
day so I'm stressed style all the time
started pulling my hair then I get hair
extensions to try to like cover that up
that makes it worse then I bleach my
hair that makes it worse when we get
married I think like a year in I look in
the mirror and I'm like I literally have
no more hair I was like I didn't even
want to leave the house anymore so
Jordan I mean a couple strands of hair
what are we talking about I know I mean
like bald spots like patches like
patches of hair and it was stress driven
stress driven and then hair extensions
so that's probably like more attraction
alopecia so what happens when you put
hair extensors in like your hair can't
withstand that weight and instead of
just losing hair where the hair
extension is with traction alopecia you
actually lose hair like around that
whole surrounding area so it was like
multiple bald spots like all over so
Jordan of course my husband he's like
wait I don't get it like why don't you
just get a wig all the Kardashians wear
wigs what's what's wrong with that so he
takes me to a wig shop in Dallas like
the first place he Googles we walk in
it's like a Halloween store like the
most expensive wig is like a plate
called swords bright neon yellow I'm
like I don't know if it's gonna work
plastic wigs they're like the most
expensive one is like 15 bucks so I
leave there like so defeated I'm like
I'm always gonna be bald you know so we
actually
um learn about this like wig shop in Los
Angeles called the wig shop actually
yeah uh from Jeffree Star
Jeffree Star who's another YouTuber
anyway long story short we fly out there
find my first wig I'm in wigs for a year
and actually when I first got my first
big I didn't tell anybody because I was
so embarrassed I was like we actually
took a trip to Chicago with my parents
and my sister-in-law and my brother and
we didn't tell them the entire time they
go oh nice haircut yeah like they I mean
these things can look so real now it's
insane so about a month into wearing it
I just felt like a fraud oh it's like I
gotta tell people I feel like I'm
probably not the only female going
through something like this I think that
like people will appreciate it and
hopefully they'll be cool with it so I
shared that I was wearing wigs and it it
kind of just opened up this door of like
all these females that are kind of going
through the same thing like this like
hidden epidemic of hair loss
um so life all the time after uh after
we had our first baby I think it's like
a known kind of like postpartum oh yeah
like issue with with hair losses so she
was talking about it all the time and I
was like I was like what do you mean
like don't worry about it she's like no
look at this are these like baby hair
whatever and it really bothered her like
I didn't even think really even to try
like what what would a solution look
like so yeah I mean I felt that it can
be very emotional like especially for
females
um because there just weren't a lot of
people talking about it so
um long story short I took the year and
wore wigs and I was like you know what
I'm just gonna focus on my scalp health
I'm going to focus on my Wellness
um and really like give this thing like
100 so meanwhile there was actually this
trend
um or I guess a hack online where a lot
of women were using Monistat
to grow their hair back which is so
strange but the reason that was working
is because it has a lot of like
anti-fungal properties
Danny you got to tell them
no you shouldn't know about it but is it
a good thing
so all the guys on the five guys would
be like what by the way we should
explain there's we always joke that we
have four female listeners hopefully
that'll change after this episode we're
all like dying inside their face right
now so Monica is what people what
females use for yeast infections okay
gotcha and so a lot of women were using
this on their scalp though and it's
helping their hair grow and people are
taking before and after pictures and
it's like insane so the reason that's
working is because it has these
anti-fungal properties in it which
nowadays you know they always tell you
don't wash your hair it's not good for
you so a lot of females are using um dry
shampoo and so they're putting all this
dry shampoo all this product that's just
like sitting on your scalp blocking your
follicle and so your hair doesn't really
have like a fair chance of growing so
when they're using Monistat you you know
it's kind of like detoxifying it's
getting rid of all that product buildup
and your hair is growing so the only
thing with that is you shouldn't be
using it long term it's just like has a
lot of harmful things in it so my goal
was to find a more natural way to
essentially accomplish the same thing so
I would like get into my bathroom and I
studied bio at the University of Texas I
was going to so did I they don't teach
you anything I learned photosynthesis
for like seven years yeah exactly I
don't teach anything about the human
body she can hang with the chemistry she
can hang she's like okay I remember that
I kind of I kind of get it but basically
how much you learn when you really need
to learn versus like by Major now I wish
I really would have paid attention
because I think it really would have
benefited me but could have known anyway
so um so you know I'm like a little
chemist in my in my bathroom I'm getting
all these ingredients from online Whole
Foods all over the place and just making
my own scalp serums and I would you know
share on YouTube like this is how I make
it this is where you order this and then
mix it this way and and then people
started asking they're like hey can you
just like ship it to me right and so I
go to Jordan I'm like I really think
this could be a thing a lot of people
when was this like a couple years ago
this was a 29th uh another probably yeah
29 2019 2019. um and so that's kind of
like where the idea originated from and
it was totally clean so it's something
that people could use every day and not
feel like it's going to be harmful so we
had a lot of like eucalyptus uh natural
ingredients jojoba oil
um but there were a lot of things I
wanted to put in it that I just didn't
have access to so long story short found
Partners found a great chemist and then
came out with our first product which
was escape room and to be honest I did
not think that it would pop off at all I
really was just like I want to serve my
Audi I've been very like service driven
with all of my content I'm like I just
really want to serve people because I
feel like if I serve them they'll come
back so that was really just like the
heart behind it but what happened was a
lot of people were buying it for like
their day were down the street or their
mom or their husband and people started
taking like before and after pictures we
never asked for before and after
pictures but I feel like that's kind of
what made it blow up right the best
marketing there is right before and
after yes people started sending in
their before and afters and like so then
I would start sharing them you know left
and right and I mean every day I'm
probably tagged in like 15 before and
afters even to this day yeah so were
there not scalp serums before that or
they were but they just weren't you know
I think it was just such a new like a
niche like you know putting something on
your scalp like a skincare routine like
creating that scalp routine was very new
people weren't really thinking about it
so I'm sure that there were scalp serums
out there
um but I don't think people were
educated about like how to use them or
why they were important
um so our biggest thing is just like if
you're taking care of your skin like you
should be taking care of your scalp it's
kind of like an extension of you know
and so um so I think once people kind of
understood how to use it then they went
to divvy first because we were also one
of the only like clean scalp serums out
there gotcha so business launches win
2020 2020 uh 2021 2021 October 2021. so
we're not even two full years in you
know and it's exploded so I don't know
how much you guys typically share do you
guys share Revenue stuff or not really
yeah I mean like our first like full
year I think you already shared it well
you said 20 is 40. but uh yeah we did
about 40 million dollars and then
um you know this year we're on track to
do 30 35 growth yeah
um it's it's crazy and that's mostly
from kind of the power of your community
or that's that plus a bunch of other
marketing that you have to do or how
does the business grow I mean that
probably exceeded your expectations I
mean that would exceed anyone's
expectations yeah I always say like when
we launched the product we thought that
we were launching it for like 10 of
Danny's audience like we were like hey
these people need to be serves Danny you
know acquired this audience they want a
resource and it just grew so far beyond
that and a lot of people think that you
know Divi
um is all Danny's audience that's been
buying it and you know she's only made
up about 15 of the overall revenue and
so it was just a product that I think
took off and worked it was just right
place right time it was like during the
era of the skinification of the scalp is
like what the beauty gurus call it and
so I missed that whole era yeah you
missed the area well it's here
either so I had to catch up I do
Starwood skin move myself I gave you two
boxes yeah I know you're you're in it
now
um and so yeah it's it's just been wild
I mean we we never expected absolutely
did you guys look at like other
creator-led businesses like who was an
inspiration that you're like oh you know
if we do this well this could be like
you know whatever yeah skims or this
could be like the Chinese Kylie's lip
thing or whatever I mean we've always
admired the Kardashians in a business
sense of like how they've how they've
like used their reality TV to grow all
these businesses and like we one thing
we love about them is like how they all
support each other it's like an
ecosystem like you're using you know
Kylie's makeup and then you're wearing
him skims and so we always loved that
aspect of what they do but I mean in
terms of like our inspiration to be
honest everyone in our space was just
launching clothing lines
um so it was totally different yeah it
was very very different were you tempted
to do that too a hundred percent Jordan
was like please don't please don't the
returns are insane my parents my dad
actually has a showroom at the uh Dallas
world uh Trade Center in Dallas so he um
you know sells wholesale tall you know
Nordstrom all these boutiques my dad
always told me he's like the one thing I
ask you is please don't get in the
fashion industry it's just yeah it's
it's a lot and so
um but one thing I knew that I wanted if
I ever did launch a business is I wanted
to have something that could be on
subscription and so a lot of my ideas
were mainly Tech at first
um I never really thought it was like
what like what would it uh you know some
service that you could get I had I
honestly didn't have like a what like
you we had this like one yeah there was
one time where she like wanted to launch
her own app because she felt like you
know she could build a better Community
like through a different platform than
Instagram and and we we tried it we
called it what did you call it the sassy
Club The Sassy Club at the time and it
was like we used this uh this
third-party app system and we drove a
large part of our community to it and we
tried to do like more the whole concept
was like let's meet in real life with
our audience and so it was like we do
meetups and stuff like that and that was
just really hard it was kind of like a
bumble right yeah it was kind of like a
bumble and so we tried that you know it
was pretty difficult and then it was it
was difficult to manage like the in face
interactions yeah let me ask you a
question I just hired a guy I paid a guy
five thousand dollars to do a couple of
like one-on-one like workshops with me
and it was all about this idea of
personal branding
which honestly a pretty lame phrase in
general like I cringed that I even did
all this but I'm putting it out there in
the spirit of authenticity so I paid
this guy why did I pay this guy well
this podcast itself has gotten pretty
popular
but uh
I've always had this problem which was
just like
um you see some people and their brand
is so clear it's like uh there's this
guy who this guy named Pomp and pomp is
all about Bitcoin he's the Bitcoin guy
yeah like you know I'm about to you know
because of Bitcoin he talked about
Bitcoin everything he loves you know
every fourth word needs to be Bitcoin
yep and then you have like um Tim
Ferriss who's you know the four hour
working guy or the four hour body
four-hour Chef he's the four-hour guy
he's all about kind of Life hacking your
way there and so you you got on the list
and a lot of people who have built good
online followings they have a clear kind
of like they're the blank guy or they're
the blank gal whatever like that that's
what they're known for
and for me I've always been like well I
don't know the business business guy
yeah that doesn't sound very like
specific or focused and I was like oh
I've gotten pretty far without that but
maybe maybe somebody could help me kind
of sharpen this so this guy who I hired
he works with like you know like Jay
Shetty and like
um a bunch of people who are like that
like uh the guy who did Quest Bar I
think yeah Tom whatever bill you
um and he's like yeah you know like Jay
Shetty his story is he was like kind of
like in and out of trouble then decided
to go be a monk and he was a monk and
then he like got kicked out of the
monastery because the monk came to him
was like you know you like some there's
something bigger in store for you so he
decided to make his life mission to
bring ancient monk wisdom in a modern
way to the world or whatever I butchered
that but something like that yeah
every day I just knew him I was like the
blue-eyed Indian guy or like you know
that's what stood out to be like the
guys they were green eyes yeah yeah but
I was like okay I see I see the value
and if you really like sharpened this
like whatever your brand is all about
but then I've met people who are maybe
like you who
um You probably never hired a consultant
or like did a brand Workshop or like sat
down with a piece of paper and like
tried to architect it seems like it kind
of happened organically and naturally
for you so I have two questions for you
one do you think you have like a focus
like that like the blank
you you are the you know just like the
Bitcoin guy like do you have like a
thing that's like our brand is is about
this word or these three words or
whatever do you have something like that
um so when I started going through my
hair loss I think was the first time
that I kind of felt like I had that
thing like I was kind of like the wig
influencer for a while and then kind of
like the hair loss influencer I mean as
cliche as it sounds I feel like
like I think our biggest thing is we've
always just been very authentic and like
goofy
um and we've kind of I feel like what
we've done is figured out how to collide
those worlds of like being professional
but also getting you know taking your
heels off getting back home just like
and being real about what it's like
having two kids like you're in heels
changing diapers kids peeing all over
you
um but like I would say it it took like
10 years for people to kind of I've
never had you know this Persona or this
video pop off and go viral and then
everyone knows who I am like I've never
had that moment it's just been like very
gradual of but I but I totally feel what
you're saying like I I still go through
those times where I'm like okay who am I
like identity what's my identity like
what do and I I do feel like there are
some bloggers out there that are so good
at like okay when you think of
Chick-fil-A you think of this one person
or when you think of like this one brand
you think of it dude that should have
been mine Chick-fil-A you're a genius
yes
and it's like and so I do try to find
those things that like okay when in
Dallas when people go here like are they
gonna what brands are they thinking
picking up when they think of Danny you
know but it's it's challenging because
also like I'm very you know one day I
want to be doing this one day I like to
like kind of shift and be on my toes
what do you think people get wrong when
they try to build a following not like
the people who are just obviously bad
but let's say people who have the
potential work could be working out what
do you think are the mistakes that those
people make that like they're trying to
be perfect all the time and it's so
unrelatable I think like one of the
biggest reasons that like people can
relate is because we have made so many
mistakes and we share them and like
there's times when we get online we're
like man that was bad we should have
done that like there was an example a
small example but I was uh cutting up
like fruit for my daughter Stella's
lunch and I'm cutting the grapes wrong
you know like where they can choke on
grapes and like had no idea like my mom
never cut my grip so like I didn't know
I was there anything wrong but you know
like the DMS start flooding in the
Facebook groups are popping often he's
like cutting the grapes
like you're influencing all these moms
to cut grapes wrong and I'm like oh my
gosh I didn't know like so you know you
get on you're like guys I'm so sorry
like I made a mistake let me like teach
you the right way to to cut grapes
instead of like deleting the content and
being embarrassed about it and so it's
like I think you cut them wrong the
second time dude I did I did I did
um but yeah so I just feel like I have a
lot of girlfriends like in Dallas that
are you know trying to do something
similar and they're trying so hard to
just be perfect all the time and it's
not just about you said the word
relatable I think that's a key uh key
thing like we had the comedian Hassan
Minaj I don't know if you have music uh
yeah it was on Netflix and stuff like
that he came on and
um
and I was asking him something about
because we do this like we're doing
these live podcasts now sometimes so
we're doing one this Saturday here in
Austin and so I had asked him I was like
Hey I'm going on stage kind of like
stand-up comedy it's gonna be whatever
like a thousand people in the audience
how do I you know any what would you say
like first five minutes how can I set a
good tone here he goes
um he gave me two pieces of an eye see
those first make it clear that you are
there so he's like talk about the room
talk about the person the front row talk
about you know the city that you're in
and like what it's been like for you to
be there like just make it like yeah
give them the fact that you're there and
everybody will be present together when
you do that and he goes the second thing
is uh low status you know low status he
goes yeah like people make this mistake
a lot that they try to be high status
they're like yeah uh I want your
approval so I'm gonna present a version
of myself that is high status when in
actuality the way people relate to you
and like you is doing something low
status so making fun of yourself showing
a weakness being vulnerable saying
something that's what makes you look bad
not great or like embarrassing to you
and so he's like you know comedy is
actually a low status art form not like
not high status which is what you like
if you go to a conference you go on
stage uh it's typically going to be all
high status stuff people trying to say
things that show how important they are
and how smart they are in their resume
and all that basically that's not how
people relate to you and so what you're
saying kind of reminds me of that is
like a uh doing things that are showing
the showing some of the flaws almost
not just because they're there but like
it actually helps it actually builds
that relatability I know I I agree I
mean I feel like the times that we
connect with our audience the most is
like in those goofy times when I'm
running around with no pants on and like
you're like oh I relate same thing you
know I think there's like a there's like
a pushback on like A-list celebrities
even towards influencers because it's
like I don't understand like this is not
relevant to my life at all what the
Kardashians are doing in the private
jets and all this stuff and like I think
that that's where people feel at home
you know is is in these kind of like
relatable moments which is what I told
Ben you need to do I feel like y'all can
do so well on the podcast is like you're
not trying to be this business Guru
expert you're just kind of talking about
everyday people's business and your
thoughts on it and you're kind of
riffing and I think that you know I told
Sean I was like I think he just needs to
do more he needs to get on Instagram
stories need to get on YouTube that was
my advice
non-private like you know yeah
when we dm'd him this private I was like
what's this guy doing yeah yeah I didn't
bother with Instagram but but what did
your your fancy branding coach tell you
so what he was saying was so they did
this they did a great exercise actually
um I kind of want to like package this
thing up so more people can do this I
think it's it's a pretty useful thing
but what he says is he was like you know
you want to figure out your signature
stories
uh first so he's like don't try to get
to the end point of oh I'm known for X
he's like go look at yours the signature
stories that made you you so like what
were the moments of your life
that kind of defined who you were times
you either made a key decision in Life
or you which could have just been like
no more like I'm not doing this ever
again or uh you know so some people have
that they give up alcohol or something
it's like that becomes their brand but
it's like the signature story is The
Rock Bottom story that they when
literally they were so embarrassed at
something that they did or felt and then
they decided never again or it could be
a single story where you know they went
from kind of being you know shy to
actually getting out there being more
confident and what what changed so you
find your signature stories that kind of
reveals
what you're going to be in what you're
going to end up being known for the
mental shortcut people will need to make
when they're trying to think about who's
that guy oh he's the guy who blah blah
blah that's there that's their story
um the second thing he said was he was
like you gotta figure out
what you said something about like
serving he's like basically people will
come to your contact because they're
trying to change the way they feel
so you got to know that you're not
giving information you're giving a
transformation of like you know emotion
how somebody feels so he's like what
transformation do they get when they
come to your content that you give them
better and more consistently than
anybody else if you do that you win and
so you got to figure out what is that
chain so like with the Pod for example
we talk about business ideas or like
we'll show you an under the radar
business you never heard of that's
really interesting crushing it but like
let me ask you I bet I bet you I bet
your answer will match what I think it
is which is why do you listen to the Pod
what do you what do you feel when you
when you listen to it I think it's like
education meets inspiration like I think
I walk away being like oh cool new idea
like I want to you know I want to learn
more about that or I feel like I can you
know go do this in our business right
and I think that that's what you guys do
really well whether it's like just
sharing ideas or you know uh uncovering
these things we've never heard of but
it's done in a relatable manner whereas
like I think that that's why it's
inspiring is because you're not doing
this in like this I'm up here you're
down here type of way it's kind of like
Hey we're all here and we can all do it
right tangible it's more tangible it's
very relatable like I think that there's
very strong parallels between what I've
seen in like Danny's content and the way
that she relates to her audience and
what you guys are doing with your
audience well we call it the girl next
door we don't want to be a supermodel we
want to be the girl next door yeah
you're still trying to be hot
relatable hot like yeah
like I can get there but yeah you are
the girl I love that how have people
like do you what are your experiences
like in real life when you meet people
who listen to the pun
uh it's probably like how what you feel
which is that they know you they're like
like
yeah you know what I mean but I really
know you we're friends yeah like like an
Instagram like daily vlogging kind of
like through an Instagram story it's
kind of the same way it's like the same
yeah your kids I know what your house
looks like I know like on my way here I
was asking my wife I was like I was like
I don't follow them on Instagram like I
don't know their stories
little I know they're like oh their mom
is like involved in it and yes they got
two kids like there's like all these
little things that are known about your
life the inside of your life and so I
think like that's what you guys do on
the podcast is different podcast is like
such a long form conversation right
unedited unscripted so you get to know
someone's personality and we I usually
do the Pod with uh my buddy Sam and Sam
like it's kind of like two friends
hanging out kicking it and so you you
hit the like the big what we found was
that the two Transformations people get
the two feelings that they get
consistently is
we're like they're entrepreneurial
friends it's almost like yeah they got
to hang out with their two guy friends
who are like super into business nerding
out about business stuff it's like they
kind of got to have the hangout without
like going and having the friends and
doing the hangout like themselves
because it's like I was driving
somewhere and I just listened right but
I kind of got my hangout fixed and the
second is like motivation or like the
inspiration like the juice to be like
I'm probably not gonna go do any of the
things you mentioned on this podcast
specifically but just hearing about
stories of people doing interesting
things made me want to go do more
interesting things or maybe if they're
doing well it made me want to go crush
it in my field too so once we realize
that it's like oh okay
that's very different than people come
to me for this specific information uh
or the specific help um because it's
like yeah there's some of that but it's
not the main thing that gets people
attached I told I told Ben this
um you know but I I said the biggest
Pitfall from here is you got to stay
humble and you got to stay consistent
because I think that what happens in
this era and and you saw it a lot with
the early tick talkers that blew up
during covid is they moved in these big
houses right you know and then they
would sign with these managers and then
they're all in all these commercials and
the very thing that made them relatable
and tangible during this was dancing
alone in their bedroom she was dancing
alone in their bedrooms now they're in
mansions and it just loses the same
sentiment right and I think that that's
the pitfall of anyone really in like the
entertainment industry but like anyone
who's built their brand off of
authenticity is like losing that right
so it'd be like you guys you know
becoming jerks you know or douchey and
then like no one wants to hang out and
they're like oh well now they're just
pompous or even like you have to protect
yourself you know in our world we have
to protect ourselves from the sponsored
thing things of like oh they're just
bought now you know like I don't trust
them anymore you know I I don't believe
that they're saying this for just
genuine reasons it's not salmon right
you know kicking it and so you probably
get this question a lot it's the same
question we get a lot which is like if
you were just starting out today what
would you what would you do right if you
were 21 now what would you where would
you start uh we get that on the business
side what would you say your your answer
to that is on the content side would you
yeah would you start on Tick Tock would
you go to Instagram yeah like what type
of content would you do because like you
had said one thing that's actually very
very interesting to me your first video
you said was like affordable New Year's
Year New Year's Eve outfits that's kind
of amazing because that's a great like
almost like title
um like it seems like from the beginning
you had a good sense of like what
content will work right yeah not
everybody has that like I think most
people would have tried something that's
like no yeah I would say like any
platform that I started on I mean I
would probably start on Tick Tock now
just because I feel like it's the
easiest to go viral Instagram is so
tough
um but I do feel like YouTube's like
kind of coming back a little bit yeah I
heard vlogging is coming vlogging
um long form but I honestly wish I
wouldn't have started out with the
trends like chasing the trends I really
wish I would have liked just like found
something really unique and honed in on
that because I feel like I was like
Trend chasing for so long and then I
would have some video pop off but that
was just because it was trendy and no
one actually wanted to get to know me
more
um so I wish I would have just like kind
of been more unique which I think kind
of just goes back to like what does
Danny actually want to share like what
is she really passionate about I would
mix in a little bit of that like I since
I was studying biology and Kinesiology I
would you know mix in a little bit of
like what I was learning in my classes
but then the next video was a trend you
know and so that's the same thing that I
feel like a lot of tick talkers get
caught up in you know they're just doing
all these trendy videos and then they
have a meet up and like no one comes
because nobody really knows them and
nobody actually like connects with them
um and then two like I think branding as
characters within your content is so
important like you said my mom's in a
lot of content so I had this idea to
call my mom what's her character so yeah
her character is we call her tornado and
that's the re the reason we call her
tornado is because she is a tornado when
she walks in the room like right now if
she was in this room she'd be dusting
off your leaves over there she'd be
fixing all the light bulbs my mom has so
much energy and I didn't really know how
to like communicate that to the audience
so my first step was like we call her a
tornado and the second step is every
time she comes over we're showing her up
on a chair dusting things off and like
doing tornado things doing tornado
things pulling me out out of my comfort
zone just like being a tornado and so
um and then you know Jordan's Jordan's
character is like every single day he
gets up at the same exact time he wears
you know he gets dressed up every single
time I'm running around the house just
like chaos so we all have our certain
characters and I didn't really learn how
important that was up until like
probably like three or four years ago
that you just sort of like because
people started forgetting who we were
and so I I had to like create a way
where people like when they when they
you know were missing like what did they
associate our family with and like how
how could they remember us throughout
the day and so
um so like tornado was was a like was
kind of huge for us I feel like that was
not like that but it was like very
relatable because you know just even
before we had kids like the content we
were creating I'm like who relates to
this we're traveling all over the world
taking outfit pictures right you know
like this is not it doesn't make sense
and honestly it was exhausting for us
because it wasn't even like relatable
for for us you know and so as soon as we
kind of like settled down and we had
kids and I was like okay we have to
figure out a way to make our everyday
life interesting like so we bought her a
nice house and then we had a vegetable
house
relatable houses go sleep in the nice
house no I honestly I know people that
do that like I know influencers that
have second houses that literally just
film there yeah our middle class house
no or I know influencers that literally
will like they'll take a Chanel bag to
dinner but they'll like switch it with
like an Amazon one before when they take
the photo and it's like
um but no I feel like what's so like
unique about us too is like that we kind
of live our lives just the way we were
raised like with the same family values
that we were raised with were not shared
to we're not scared to share that with
our with our audience yeah I mean I
would say like everything you said a lot
about like characters this is like who
they are you know and it was just like
how do we kind of like tell it from all
these different angles and it just fit
you know like every family is a story
right I think that that's where a lot of
the creativity seeped into what we did
right and why it was hard to do what we
did is we had to find what made our our
family unique and almost produce it like
a reality TV show and I think that that
I mean I don't want to say that we were
the first but I think that that's what
we saw the medium of Instagram stories
as like a lot of I think influencers in
like the 2019 era when it came out we
were like oh my gosh like how am I gonna
do this because they're not super
personable and we you know with your
YouTube background we're like oh man
this is like our platform to shine and
it was it was so fun it's what I'm
pushing you to do is like show your wife
show your kids like show the behind the
scenes of like what is happening in
Sean's life beyond just this podcast
like that's what I think and it doesn't
even have to be family it could be like
your producer or your assistant or
whoever it is like my my brother now has
an assistant her name's Katie and she
shows up like three days a week and she
is everyone like loves her on the
content and now because they love her
and because she's a character they go
out and do these crazy things that they
probably would have never done that's
just so much more entertaining now
because there's another character
involved and so who's are you just like
selfie with the camera do you have
somebody who else you're right this guy
hello my name is Jordan okay but this
guy I mean yeah it's we do have a
content creator now that we actually
just hired yeah it works with like reels
because those are that's a different
thing that's a whole other Beast so you
know he's been helping out a little bit
but like we kind of just enjoy doing it
ourselves there's a lot I talked to
another woman who listens the Pod so
Rebecca zamorolo she's like a YouTuber
she's got like 10 million Subs on
YouTube and when I called her she was
basically like yeah downstairs right now
is like the camera crew they basically
live in our house and she's like my dog
has a channel that's got like 300 000
Subs like we have our gaming channel we
have our she does like kind of kids like
role play content or something like that
yeah story kind of like yeah let's like
treasure chest in the backyard let's go
do whatever yeah and so they not only
each one not only there's a character
each one got their own sub channels has
their own following and then they have
camera crew that was like just there all
the time I was like man that's you know
like stressful or like just it's like a
lot like it's like reality TV it's like
you know famous people they have trouble
when they go out because they're like oh
I keep getting stopped but almost like
influencers have it in the house it's
like I never get to just not yeah have
you said the same thing yes oh my gosh
it's it's hard and I love our team to
death but you know it's it's hard when
your job is to live your life you know
your job is to to experience life to
capture it in a very raw strip down way
but you know when there's Crews and
there's teams it's it's sometimes
counterproductive to what you're trying
to do it and so you know the reason I
think that the husband and wife Dynamic
works so well in our Niche is because it
it's just us hanging out you know and
it's like it's the best content there
and he had a bin in her life that was
like falling around that wasn't her
husband it's like it's all about the
Dynamics right and so like I you know
it's funny I always advocate for like
the best producer for a content creator
is going to be the husband in fact I
think that the most successful uh
couples in our Niche have that husband
wife Dynamic where they're creating
content together it is funny we have our
so we do have a team and they come over
like four days a week but they they meet
in our upstairs playroom and so they're
not the ones actually filming the
content but they're there yeah
we have more kids it was like okay we're
just gonna put this ball pit in here
okay here's Stella's table and so Stella
will walk in and just be playing over
there but the amount of times that we've
tried to you know get a workspace or get
an office it just like doesn't work
because they do have to be there because
like if we're going into an office every
day that's not relatable anymore right
and there's also like nothing I don't
know it's truly one of the most like
like technical nuances that's difficult
about our industry
um is like how do we position our team
where do we put them and then like Danny
can't you know you can't just say hey
Danny come to the office and do a try on
haul all the clothes are in the the
closet right but so it's always the
trade-off of okay do we have people in
our house what do we do yeah we're still
figuring it out still figuring out and
for the like Instagram kind of like
sponsored content or like brand new
deals um tell me a little bit about
those so how uh
how those kind of like changed over time
what what it what is like working the
best or what works yeah what doesn't
work anymore or it doesn't work at all
when people try it yeah so I mean
brandell started out as you know here's
a product go make a YouTube video
include it for 20 seconds put the link
in there and like At first I was such a
sellout because you know like you're I'm
20 years old I'm like I'm just trying to
pay my rent like I'll do anything that I
can do to just like get by and so and
then I think you get to a point where
you're like wait like people really
trust me like this is like some
responsibility so I kind of like took
this approach where I pictured myself
like you know shopping with them and
then purchasing something then trying it
and then them being like what the heck
Danny why'd you recommend this so I
really started to take like more
responsibility and like wait I am a
resource like I Gotta Serve these people
not only that I have to find the best
deals not only that like I need to go
after these Brands and beg them for
better promo codes that like they can't
get anywhere else so it kind of became
like competitive with myself yeah we
kind of became like like a like a QVC
always gonna have the best deal and so
we tried to adopt that mentality
in-house you know we I always describe
it as like a like a like a triangle like
at the top is the audience and like as
long as we're prioritizing them first
everyone's happy at the bottom left is
like our business which we have to take
care of we run a team and then on the
right is like the brand we're serving
and we found that every time we try and
flip the triangle a different way so if
we put the brand at the top then the
audience is like you don't actually like
this product and everything kind of just
crumbles and the the I would say like
this year in particular kovid especially
it was like there was just this like
craze for promo codes like because what
the shopping was happening so much
through Instagram that we found our Edge
to be like hey let's get the best deal
that you're not gonna find anywhere else
you know in the country and it kind of I
mean yeah but I think what works a lot
for us is to not just go 100 on brand
deals but to also couple that with
affiliates so when I post you know ltk
so when I share something that I would
like to know like to know it yes so like
to know is basically a platform where
you know anything I swipe up to you can
make commission off of it but the best
thing about ltk is I can share things
that I genuinely bought like this top
right now I got from Target I purchased
it I get to go tell people okay it kind
of fits a little tight in the shoulder
so maybe go a size up you know here's
the link make sure you order it in white
because that's about to sell out
whatever it is and so that's like super
authentic super real people know that
you're making commission off of it they
don't care because you're just providing
them like a lot of value so that's like
50 of how we monetize and then the other
half is you know through brand deals
where I feel like if you have a really
strong affiliate base like you can get
really picky with the brands that you're
you're choosing so we got super picky
like the past couple years and um and
then it got to a point where like okay
we're getting brand deals we got
Affiliates now let's go after those
brands that have never given promo codes
or never given deals let's fly out there
and like meet with them in person and
like beg them for promo codes so one of
those examples was free people you know
girls love free people I've been wearing
free people for years they never do
promo codes they rarely do they'll go on
sale but never do like a discount code
so we begged them forever to get a code
finally got a code you know within the
first hour we pushed seven figures
because people are like and not only
that but because we I had worn it for
years and people had seen these you know
these specific uh crop tops that I've
been wearing for so long it was like the
most like gen like authentic push and it
like benefited the brand benefited us
benefited the audience everyone's happy
and so what's the juiciest brand deal
you've ever had where you were like wow
they're gonna pay us that like that's a
stupid amount of money or like you know
we can make this work you don't say the
name of the brand or you could just
describe
I know what you're gonna say I think you
say it Stanley yeah Stanley Stanley
water yeah so fun fact we were like why
are those like so popular we were the
first to share them yeah first blockers
and I was like this is humongous this is
a giant giant cup it's it's a great
product you know they are owned by pe
um and so we flew up to Seattle and we
were like guys listen because they
really hit that like Utah Mormon Market
really well yeah it's a great Market
um and then they saw that that was
working the the president is a guy named
Terence he's actually a phenomenal like
marketer he was the one who put post
Malone and Crocs in like kind of like
reverse Crocs trajectory to being like a
cultural icon and so he uh I think had
noticed Danny and was like Hey you know
like I there's something about this mom
Market that's working with Stanley
um you know flew us up there and uh it
was it was hard they still haven't given
us a code per se on the quencher or have
they not on the quencher we have a code
on every other product but yeah that's
it's hard but yeah they um they've been
good
we have some special things coming out
with them we're excited yeah we're
excited amazing
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
so pain points right so like you talked
about how Divi was born out of a pain
point that you had yeah
um I'm curious as you guys are trying to
run this kind of influencer business
plus Divi like have you felt any pain
points that you're like God I wish I
wish somebody just made this easier or
made this hiring people you see here
yeah wait this is kind of random but
like content creation at weddings
can't take creation at weddings yes so I
feel like now Brides really want like
tick tocks or reels or just like iPhone
photos they don't want to like hire this
photographer and wait you know two
months before they get their photos back
so at my wedding I just hired someone to
like take an iPhone and like take an
iPhone video walk around it's a good
idea that's a great idea that's a great
idea take photos and I just paid them
like hourly but I feel like you could
get like a pretty good team that like
you know they take all this the nice
thing is too you get your content the
day after the wedding because like the
biggest bummer is you go to your
honeymoon you don't have any pictures
yeah let me post and like people are
gonna pay for that because it's their
for one day a normal videographer I
think is like 10 grand
sometimes I don't even I like the iPhone
like you said like my sister-in-law just
got married like a few months ago she
just now got like the first cut of the
wedding video and then that doesn't look
like what content looks like nowadays
exactly it looks like this thing
it's like nice yeah but it's like if you
posted this it's like okay Grandma like
you know what this is not like uh I
would rather had like five tick tocks
and like six Instagrams yeah that like
felt like the fun of the party you know
I think the reason we've noticed that is
because Jordan films a lot of our
content and we've we've been to a lot of
weddings where the next day the bride is
like reached out to me like hey can you
send me that reel that you posted or uh
your stories for the day and we're like
oh they already expired like they're
they're done they're gone you know
there's so many like content creators
now that I feel like don't want to be
influencers they're just like content
creators like they'll just create
content for other people I think
someone's gonna that's always been a
great idea you had thank you I had more
time
that's cool because that could just be
like local franchises you could uh just
train someone in theory you could just
start that business and then be like I'm
looking for an operator in Nashville we
need an operator in Florida yeah who's
gonna be able to do these like dispatch
content creators so easy and they go in
and then they like cut it all up and
then they have it to you by midnight
yeah who did you you said there's a
bunch of content creators that don't
want to be influencer so who are they
what are they what are they doing yeah I
would say like we've seen this a lot
with like Divi it's it's called ugc now
so it's like uh user generated content
so there's like a brand yeah there's
like a whole economy now uh they're not
getting paid like as a brand deal to
promote it on their own stories it's
like you know hey we'll pay you two
thousand dollars for four videos with
our brand a month and so these Brands
will have uh 10 ugc creators on standby
on retainer you know and they use that
content for ads and so what is happening
is like our like our ugc content at Divi
is performing the best over any type of
like a branded asset and so it makes it
sort of feel like a lot of people are
using the brand in an organic ways and
they they are but it's a whole other new
class and I was like oh my gosh people
are doing that like that's insane yeah
we pay for our brand we pay like between
one and two thousand dollars to a
handful of creators for this exact thing
and it's like they don't have a
following yeah they're just like good at
creating this content and uh they're
like wow you know I get free product and
I get paid to do this like this is
amazing and I don't even need to be
famous like I felt the hit even with my
brand deals like we don't get a lot of
those opportunities more because they
used to come to me and they used to say
we'll pay you x amount but now I guess
we're too expensive or something because
we never here for them anymore well it's
kind of shifted to like that's
interesting part about like how the
influencer industry shift is it's it
always kind of goes in waves right but
it's like moving from like back to mass
marketing where it's like as many people
as possible are using and talking about
your product at the same time and so
that goes viral on Tick Tock see how it
goes so where does Divi go from here so
you guys are at this level now are you
guys you have like a retail distribution
too right yeah so last year we did about
eight percent of our revenue from retail
but we are scaling in Ulta so we're
hoping to be in all doors of Ulta by the
end of this year
um I don't know Danny's always been big
on like not taking investors so we
didn't do that at the front end and so
we're kind of like we own our own
destiny at this point um I think that
we're very passionate about the mission
but Divi like it's hard to create an
influencer brand that people don't think
you just slapped your name on it right
so we really wanted to create a product
that is more and bigger than Danny and
so the products have to be really good
um and so we're really focused right now
on Innovation we're trying to patent
some of our Technologies
um why is it called Divi what's the name
yeah you answered this I always forget
it's just like divvying up attention to
like each area of your life like overall
better lifestyle and overall Wellness
but is it one of those things where it
just sounds cool then later you're like
what's the meaning or you're like I
always really want to know it was just
so hard to trademark yeah
she gets mad when I say this but I was
like yeah it's the third name all the
other songs it was like the 30th name
like
um it's a good name yeah it's good yeah
now I like I love it now but and uh so
you're going to reach tell you hired a
bunch of people you said yeah what else
is like what's the next unanswered
question for you guys what are you
trying to figure out next I would say
like you know last year was very
difficult uh just because like it was
kind of Danny and I running everything
we've now like you said hired like this
Suite of VPS
um let's say the next biggest challenge
for us is like we're kind of setting the
stage for in 2024 to go International
um which some companies have done really
well and other companies have really
botched yeah um and it's been just like
a money pit and so that's probably the
next Frontier for us and you know we
would like to do it without having to
raise additional Capital we've done
everything thus far ourselves um which
is very unique I mean the best part is
like our audience is kind of built in so
when we launch something people tell me
that day if they like it or not or that
day what they want more of and so you
know our sequence or what we've launched
we only have four skus right now has
just been like listening to our audience
and that's the biggest one of the
biggest things is can you sell
International and so so we're definitely
working on that and then just like a lot
of other skus in the pipeline since we
only have four skus we have a lot of
product development's been the hardest
thing to learn for us for sure
and so there's like that uh company like
seed beauty that was doing stuff for
forgot who Kylie or something like that
yeah there's like these companies that
are behind a lot of influencer Brands
like uh I know like the prime drink or
whatever there's like these guys behind
it that totally they have their own
company they do like multiple Brands out
of that did you guys work with somebody
like that or did you do your own
sourcing and Manufacturing we found a
manufacturer and that's pretty much it
um formulation how did you do that you
went to like a formulation house or
whatever kind of the same yeah like
manufacturers usually have chemists
in-house and so we've found one and it
it they developed our serum and luckily
we just picked one right that's a very
hard world to navigate to I've learned
um I think we totally got lucky with our
manufacturer on the first one because
there's a lot of bad manufacturers out
there and you don't know until six
months later right and so picking the
good ones has been hard but yeah other
than that I mean we have two in-house
chemists now yeah we have two in-house
chemists we we again with the influencer
business like Danny learned so much from
having a manager we've always just tried
to be entrepreneurs in-house and
bringing a house which is usually longer
you make more mistakes it's harder but I
mean I think that we like where we're at
where we didn't have a Cody or someone
come in and say just slap your name on
this because we're able to listen to our
audience develop the products that we
know that they want and uh but yeah it's
more challenging for sure I didn't see
him at all last year yeah I'm like I
have a life now I play paintball now so
like I'm good now but people around you
I play paintball now so no and it's also
the first time now we have like our four
VPS when we walk into a room and we're
like hey we have an idea can we do this
yeah that's the political process of how
we get things done and now there's
process everywhere whereas like you know
if we have an idea today and the content
side we're like okay let's make it
happen you know and it's just it's
becoming a real company which is it's
cool but it comes yeah I have to be
careful Jordan tells me when we walk
into the office he's like you can't just
walk into the office and tell them what
you want like we've been working on this
product for eight months she's like yeah
I don't really like it you know it's
like wait wait just don't say it there's
crushing hopes of dreams I'm sorry do
you think you'll be doing content in
like five years ten years 100 I'm
obsessed I'm obsessed with my job like I
love creating content yeah yeah I don't
even think of it as a job but it's it's
honestly like so I I think it like
our relationship I feel like is always
really healthy whenever we're like
creative together and creating things
together and I think we love doing that
um Instagram therapy basically yes
pretty much I miss you guys connected
well if you work with your wife like you
I feel like you have to work through so
much more conflict than if you have nine
to five like I mean we yeah it's it's it
makes our relationship stronger I mean
with something like a larger goal and
then you know
um but we'll see like how it evolves
with involving our family like our kids
that's something I still haven't really
figured out
um and that's what's so great about
working with Jordan is like if we ever
didn't want to share our kids or go down
that path like him and I can just take
over again
um and then also having Divi we don't
have to rely on on sharing the entire
family
um but no I think it's something that
we'll probably always be doing yeah
we're sure well on Instagram yeah so
people can find us on Instagram under
Danny Austin
um and then Divi diviofficial.com
um and then Instagram divvy official yep
yeah what about you where's your
Instagram oh I don't you don't even have
one I don't have one as soon as you got
a spin-off characters
it's so much effort that I I couldn't I
couldn't it would cause conflict in our
marriage to try and do both like yeah
I'm a great supporting actor that's
right amazing if people want to come
work for you how would they mind you
yeah yeah if you want yeah if uh if you
guys want to come work for Divi email
hello diviofficial.com and it'll get to
me yeah awesome well thanks for doing
this I know this is definitely you're
probably like what the heck is this
podcast who are these guys but uh you
know I appreciate you coming on this is
fun this is fun thanks for having us
[Music]
foreign